das nächste superlativ steht an und zwar
die größte youtube party aller zeiten in
deutschland in einer riesendisco im pm
in untermeitingen es wird nämlich auch
ein riesen event mit dabei zb der dj der
guten laune wird dabei sein
werden kräftig abfeiern herr tutorial
und clixoom christoph karten ich bin
natürlich auch dabei und ihr könnt auch
dabei sein es gibt tausende karten und
10 2 die könnte hier gewinnen wenn ihr
clixoom und krieg für musik abonnenten
seit und folgendes wisst welche
internationale star htm stagediving
gemacht recherchiert mal ein bisschen
kann man auch als video im netz sehen
und dann schreibe es in die kommentare
aber schreibt die kommentare nicht ab
weil das ist schon das ein oder andere
mal schief gegangen also ich drücke euch
die daumen und dann sehen wir uns in
untermeitingen am 16